representatives from 40 countries and
international organizations have
discussed the reconstruction of ukraine
not after but while the fighting still
rages but isn't this a little premature
and will the principles they agree on
have any lasting impact this is inside
story
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm sahil
rahman more than four months of war has
destroyed countless cities and towns in
ukraine its allies though want to start
rebuilding as soon as possible
more than 40 nations and international
organizations have outlined priorities
for the reconstruction of ukraine they
met two thousand kilometers west of kiev
in the swiss city of logano where they
agreed on the legano principles the
guidelines include strengthening the
rule of law fighting corruption and
improving sustainability
but it's no small task prime minister
denis shimhel estimates the cost of
rebuilding ukraine at 750 billion
dollars
what binds all of us in this room
together is the desire in this time of
horror
wanton destruction and grief
to provide the people of ukraine with
the prospect of a return to a life of
self-determination
peace and a bright future
that road is long
but it is never too early to prepare for
the time
when the weapons fall silent
europe
has a special responsibility
and a strategic interest
to be at ukraine's side every step of
the way
ukraine wants to be part of our european
union and we want ukraine to become a
member of the european union
ukraine is highly motivated to work with
us in this direction
and we will do our utmost to support
these efforts well russia needs to be
held to account for this appalling war
that has been perpetrated in ukraine and
we are looking at options for uh the
deployment of russian assets we've
discussed it as the g7 and many of our
allies are also looking at how we can
make sure that russia is contributing to
ukrainian recovery
well we'll begin our discussion in a
moment but first alan fisher has this
report from the ukrainian city of urbin
when the international community is told
it will take somewhere in the region of
750 billion dollars to rebuild ukraine
it sounds like a lot of money because it
is a lot of money and a lot of that will
be spent on big infrastructure programs
like rebuilding bridges and roads
rebuilding the water system that have
been destroyed in the first few months
of the war
but also boils down to something like
this
a place where a woman called natalya
called home she lived here with her
three children and her husband and it
was destroyed during the russian advance
and as you can see there's absolutely
nothing left everything she has
has gone and there are thousands of
homes tens of thousands of homes around
this country that'll have to be rebuilt
even today we're seeing engineers and
builders who are looking at buildings
nearby that have been hit and affected
by what's happened over the last couple
of months to see what can be rebuilt or
what will have to be pulled down and all
of that costs money now we know that in
the early days of the war some six
million people left the country there
are eight million internally displaced
people and many of them haven't seen
their homes yet they will come back
to scenes like this places that are
absolutely completely destroyed and to
rebuild them the ukrainian government
knows it needs money and to rebuild them
the ukrainian government knows that that
money has to come from international
donors but natalya also wants the
international community to know that
when they give that money they're
helping her and her family get back into
a home because at the moment all they
have
is nothing
alan fisher for inside story
so let's bring in our guests for this
edition of inside story in copenhagen
elena procopenco the co-chairwoman of
the transatlantic task force on ukraine
and a fellow at the german marshall fund
of the united states in london timothy
ash a senior emerging market sovereign
strategist at blue bay asset management
and in christian sun norway hannah
celeste a director of the security
studies program at ukrainian prison a
foreign policy and security think tank a
war welcome to all of my guests elena
can i just begin with you i mean the
war's not over uh this conference is on
talking about reconstruction even only
last week at the nato conference uh in
madrid uh ukraine in
ukraine and its president were asking
for more munitions uh the war is ongoing
is this a subject that's far too early
to be discussed and far too early to be
having a meeting about
well given the immensity of the
reconstruction needs and reconstruction
efforts that ukraine will have to engage
in one cannot start too early uh it is
critical that uh by the time one it will
be possible to start the actual
reconstruction uh all the necessary
financial and political mechanisms uh
are in place
moreover the recovery will
of course require massive financial
resources therefore it is already import
important and crucial to start
confiscating russian assets in the west
so that they are readily available by
the time when the circumstances allow
for their construction to start and and
and finally uh this immense effort will
require outstanding coordination
uh coordination of
a very complex pool of actors in ukraine
and abroad therefore this conference was
um
an important opportunity to set up those
combination mechanisms and to establish
the platforms that will allow for
the coordination to start and the
approaches to
this recovery have been uh agreed upon
so i think it was successful
and of course we're going to delve into
those issues within the next half hour
hannah would you agree with all of that
yes but also you need to understand that
when we are talking about so-called
martial plan for ukraine we are talking
not only about the physical
reconstruction of all those objects that
been uh destroyed at the territory of
ukraine first of all uh ukraine been
asking for the restoration of schools
hospitals that's something what you need
already at the liberated territories but
also all those money is that ukraine
requested part of them are going for the
reforms reforms needed for the european
integration of the country and ukraine
just received the status of the country
some of them are needed for the energy
independence of the country that's also
the question that we already can resolve
not waiting for the uh end of the war
some of them are for the digitalization
ukraine already being on the pass
in this direction and considering how
now in these work conditions a lot of
the processes being impossible to
implement in the offline so digital pass
for the estate services for example is
quite an important way uh so
what we are called reconstruction it's
not only the reconstruction plan it's
more of the recovery and the
modernization and development plan
exactly what the marshall plan been uh
70 years ago of course tim can i just
bring you in here because obviously this
meeting that uh is is happening in
switzerland has slightly morphed from
what would have been really an eu
meeting to discuss how ukraine needs to
improve to become an eu member into what
is now a larger conversation about eu
ukraine's recovery uh after a war
planning these sorts of things are one
thing setting about how you get the
money together and who does what is an
immense task and with that comes a very
large price tag
when you heard about this what was your
initial reaction about trying to rebuild
while there's a war still going on
well the two phases to this right the
the first one is funding ukraine's
conduct of the war and make sure he was
successful and numbers came out this
week about that 65 billion to year end
and then when the presumably there is
going to be a piece um you know we
will need to be a reconstruction and i
think the west will will want to make
sure that ukraine is successful so then
we're into sort of the reconstruction
numbers that have been mentioned i mean
700 billion it's finger-in-the-air stuff
really um i mean kind of what we know is
there's been a big real gdp decline in
ukraine probably 30 40
it's a dollar exchange rate move if you
think about dollar gdp it's about 200
billion before the war it's probably
going to be about 100 billion after
that's 100 billion loss and then there's
the infrastructure hits has already been
mentioned
huge uh impacts on airports on roads on
schools hospitals you name it you know
it's very hard
to put a figure on that i mean the
ukrainians have been quite systematic
they've gone through the list of of big
infrastructure they've lost and they're
also thinking about housing residential
et cetera and they come to this figure
700 billion you know uh it could be
anywhere from 300 to 700 but it's a very
very big number and someone's got to pay
for it and as has already been mentioned
there is already a big pot of money that
is very accessible that's 300 billion
dollars of frozen central bank of russia
reserves it's in the fed it's in the
bank of england the ecb we have access
to it
i think it should be confiscated and
used for eukary ukraine reconstruction
it's it's ridiculous to think
that you know western taxpayers have got
to pay these 700 billion when the
country that's been doing the damage
russia it's clear-cut russian missiles
russia attacks on ukraine it is
responsible for
war crimes and the loss of huge amount
of instruction it's your pay the money
is there we need to make sure we make
the legal changes required if there are
any changes needed to make sure these
russian assets are deployed to ukraine
to fund that reconstruction and let me
just quickly come in there because
that's part of the next question is is
there a legal way to fund this when you
talk about the oligarchs and
confiscating their money without them
coming back
uh to you might say the courts in the
future and saying what was done to us
was unfair and illegal have you ever had
any experience or through your contacts
of this that sort of scenario that that
this could this could happen it is a
possibility or are we actually venturing
into uh new areas of the sort of legal
realm of confiscating individuals assets
and using them to rebuild the country
well there is a precedent which was the
the first gulf war when iraq was made to
pay reparations to kuwait so on the
sovereign side
i think it should be fairly clear-cut
you know the 300 billion in assets i
mentioned was the central bank of russia
i mean that's essentially the russian
state i think we'd all accept that the
russian state is responsible for this
war so it should be made to pay and then
there's the oligarch money i mean again
i i'm you know i'm not quite sure
exactly how much it has has been frozen
but we're talking about tens of billions
of dollars
and then i think it's a case-by-case
basis and i think it's up to the the
western legal authorities to make sure
they build a good cast-iron case but
remember you know many of these
oligarchs are extensions of the russian
state
uh their uh their enterprises very often
act on russian state interests so again
but the west will have to prove that the
g7 communique from last week spelled it
out i mean essentially said we want to
explore ways to do this it's up to the
individual uh it's a case-by-case basis
it depends on the individual western
countries and their own legal systems
how we do it okay hannah you you want to
come in there
yes i absolutely agree uh regarding the
estate marty but about the oligarchs you
need to um think a little bit more
creative uh first of all most of those
whose frozen essence we have espionage
are under the sanctions and in the
sentence mechanism it's written very
clearly why they are there not just
because they are rich but because they
had a very direct connection to the
kremlin they are supporting their
policies but uh from another side we uh
can make the parallels with the latest
uk legislation for example when you need
to prove what is the uh um from where is
your assets yeah when you're buying for
example uh property in london and that's
been done exactly because a lot of the
russian oligarchs and the
state servants been just laundering
money in
london and in general in the united
states so here it is the same if these
oligarchs will be able to prove where is
this money if this money illegal or not
and as we know from many of the
investigations about the offshores and
about the
activities of these oligarchs most of
these money they will not be able to
prove uh what is the real source of that
okay well let me come to elena then
because obviously if you have this big
pot of money available and there's very
uh there's options of oligarch money
that's been confiscated there's also the
talk of going to financial institutions
of which we have tim here obviously
as an expert to talk to us about it but
much is being said elena about the
marshall plan obviously for some viewers
who might not know what that is it was a
plan uh created by the americans in
europe after uh post-world war ii to
rebuild uh europe and to make sure that
trade and communities could thrive after
what was a terrible global conflict much
as being said about the marshall plan
and implications of that in this
particular case do you see similarities
that can be used well first of all i'd
like to say that during this ukraine
recovery conference uh taking place in
lugano uh there have been a number of uh
bilateral commitments made in terms of
reconstruction of ukraine the eu
announced that it would establish a
platform uh for ukraine recovery and
will allocate 100 billion euros for the
recovery effort uh there were also a
number of commitments from
uh bilateral partners to take over the
uh reconstruction of specific ukrainian
cities and regions but uh i got the
impression that the marshall plan per se
in its full uh and it's a full-fledged
version is not perceived by
ukraine's international partners as
something that's uh timely right now it
seems like uh these individual efforts
and uh setting up of the
general uh reconstruction platform will
be the focus and the
the uh priority for the next uh uh few
months whereas the uh full-fledged uh
marshall plan uh is uh something that
international partners seem to be
um
uh putting um
on hold right now and
i i didn't get the impression that this
is something that's already discussed in
depth uh in the framework of this
conference
tim let me bring in here because
obviously a lot of money and figures is
being banded around at the moment
certainly by those that are at this
conference in switzerland and yet their
respective uh populations are watching
what's going on back home you're in
london uh elena is in copenhagen and
hannah is in norway and these countries
are all offering money to ukraine at a
time and i'm sure you can tell us about
the markets where the public is worrying
about how much food they can put on the
table how
um fuel prices are increasing and
they're seeing their government offering
another nation billions and billions
of dollars
how is that sitting
within the markets about the way people
feel and the way you're seeing
investments
well you know i think populations in
west european countries and well western
countries i think your understanding of
ukraine's plight i think people get it
that uh this is a challenge to our
system of governments our you know the
way we work the way we live putin is a
threat there's a cost and a price to pay
unfortunately you know it's been paid
through high inflation it's very painful
our governments need to work hard harder
to uh target support for poorer sections
of of our populations but in the end you
know we have to think how are we going
to pay this and again going back why
should western taxpayers pay
when there is hundreds of billions of
dollars of russian money sitting there
in in the west that we can use for the
reconstruction so in reality there's no
reason why western taxpayers should have
to pay for this you know russia should
have to pay for the damage it's uh it's
been carried out in ukraine i would have
you mentioned the market
i mean one thing that you know the
market can uh partner up with the
official sector with the taxpayer
western taxpayer and the russian central
bank assets etc um you know uh big banks
uh international financial markets i
think will be willing to buy into this
ukraine recovery once there's peace
but official lenders need to think
carefully about you know how at the
moment ukraine support is working at the
moment uh ukraine's four to five billion
uh monthly deficit is being funded by
some uh western governments but a lot of
it has been funded by debt at the end of
the year ukraine could end up with a 100
gdp ratio it could end up with a default
debt restructuring which would actually
make the market access very difficult
once the war ends you could have a
complicated debt restructuring and then
market access will be limited for two
years the private sector will be less
willing to lend so i think those
governments that are providing funding
to ukraine at the moment needs to change
the orientation away from debt to credit
to sorry grant aid
that's an interesting uh way of looking
at it because hannah obviously uh it's
been made very clear by everybody that's
attending uh in switzerland that this is
not a pledging conference it's a way of
looking forward and how much all of this
would would cost and i can see a a elena
also agreeing to that but we've seen
historically
hannah pledging conferences in the
before afghanistan yemen syria somalia
palestine and iraq
in some cases they benefited on a very
small level to these sorts of um
pledging conferences and the money never
actually turned up do you think this is
going to be different uh this is going
to be different first of all because
that is not just a pledging conference
but that is the annual conference about
the uh reconstruction of ukraine and the
reforms in ukraine and the original name
of this event before the war because
it's been planned several months as you
go is exactly the uh ukraine reform
conference we had it already in
london in copenhagen in uh village so
there will be that is the force of the
fifth already and those who've been
coming there they talked a lot also
about reforms in ukraine what ukraine
can do so that is not just the
conference of donors and those that you
named about the syria iraq or yemen they
were predominantly donors conference
when they were coming looking what they
have in their pockets and how they can
sponsor their certain reconstruction in
the country the idea behind this
conference in lugan being much wider
because uh as partners ukraine and our
uh partners around the world wanted to
discuss what should be the future of
ukraine what type of ukraine we would
like to build so it's not just money
that we are giving to reconstruct the
school but also how to make ukraine more
efficient in times of work how to help
our financial system or what to do with
our energy system so when we are coming
to the end of the war uh we are not
starting from the scratch but we also
already have a certain plan uh what the
future of ukraine should be but many of
the things what you came should be it
should be done already not wasting time
when the war is over and of course
though that's an overview of course
alana kind of bring you in here because
it's estimated that
45 million square meters of housing has
been destroyed 256 enterprises 656
medical institutions and 1177
educational institutions have been
damaged destroyed or seized
obviously the job has to start from the
bottom upwards and you have to start on
a small
level to get the community involved at
the ground level i mean how do you see
recovery it's easy to sort of say so
much money is required for all of this
but somebody has to actually do it and
they have to organize it how do you see
the process moving on uh well i'd like
to to come back on on what uh hannah
previously said about this um this
conference being not just about recovery
but also about reforms and and uh it's
uh there's a number of very concrete
steps that the ukrainian government can
already move forward with without
waiting for the war to be uh won and i
uh and i believe that these steps will
be critical for the uh success of their
construction effort eventually and i
primarily mean uh of course
anticorruption efforts
and a number of conditionalities that
ukraine
committed to comply with when it was
given the
eu canada status recently uh it is
critical to um to
ensure the appointment of the leadership
of inter-corruption institutions and
while ukraine has one of the most
advanced and corruption infrastructures
in the world it is important to make it
fully functional and there are a number
of other steps that are
important to to
conduct and to to make right now as to
the process going forward i think that
while the um partnerships and um
assistance packages that have been
announced at this conference are uh are
quite impressive and and ukraine very
much appreciates that um i believe more
assistance packages and commitments will
follow as soon as uh the ukrainian
government releases uh the finalized
plan of the recovery because as of now
at the conference only a summary of the
plan and priorities of the plan have
been uh announced so i believe um it is
important to see the uh
just to see the detailed plan in each
specific area for the international
community to be able to commit so yes it
is not a pledging conference because the
war is still ongoing and because the uh
recovery plan is still a living document
and and it is really uh critical to
engage um
local communities to engage mayors to
engage regional uh leadership because
this is what the uh decentralization
reform was uh was for this this is why
uh
this is why uh the last uh
eight years have been um have been
committed uh among other reforms to
making sure that communities have a say
and have the seat at the table in
the efforts to reform the country
including now on the recovery asset so i
am uh i i can see some concerns with
regard to um making this recovery
process inclusive enough let me uh i've
heard from let me just jump in there
because hannah's agreeing but i want to
just come back to timothy because
obviously tim you know the financial
institutions are listening to the noises
coming out of lagano at the moment are
these are sorts of are these the sorts
of conversations words that they want to
hear about you know
dealing with corruption getting the
community involved in at the grassroots
level because even marcus bent who's
head of the european international bank
is saying that you know you have to
start at a macro level you have to start
at ground level to start rebuilding and
you also have to make sure the bombs
stop
well absolutely i mean you need peace
you need macro stability
uh issues like fighting corruption we're
there before the war they're going to be
there after the war but what i would
highlight i mean this idea
you can't get an impression that somehow
the west needs to intervene and you know
run ukraine after after the war i mean
actually
ukrainians have done an incredible job
in stopping an enormous russian military
machine i mean they've shown ingenuity
and innovation you know the the
electricity works the railways work
uh institutions work i mean that's
utterly remarkable so
i think once the war stops uh new
ukraine and and not the old ukraine
which was probably oligarchs i think
it's a real opportunity again to
flourish and build on what was achieved
uh
during this this conflict which is you
know uniting the country
focusing the country on on delivering a
victory
uh and i think you know it's almost like
a state of israel moment for ukraine
right i mean it's kind of you know
they've rallied around
they've
they've worked together and achieved
some remarkable things and i think
actually
um the reconstruction and recovery could
be a huge success you know with this
with this focus with the ambition with
western support with financing hopefully
from those frozen
russian assets and with the innovation
and ingenuity that this you know 40
million people big country important
country in europe uh can deliver i think
the private sector will be very
interested to get involved in that well
we'll see what happens unfortunately we
have to leave it there it's been a very
interesting chat i'm sure we'll come
back to it again in the future i'd like
to thank my guests
alana prokorpenko in copenhagen timothy
ash in london and hannah schillat in
christian son in norway
and thank you for watching this edition
of inside story you can see the program
again anytime by visiting our website at
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter our handle there is at aj
inside story from me so ramen and the
inside story team here in doha thanks
for your time and your company
[Music]